wisst ihr noch als spaziergang ein
harmloses unverdächtiges jahr
unschuldiges wort war sowie wandertag
oder picknick meine damen und herren der
spaziergang hat seine unschuld verloren
unschuld verloren zehntausende geben
jedenfalls jede woche in dutzenden orten
deutschlandweit auf die straße und
spaziergang ist dabei längst ein
kampfbegriff geworden synonym des corona
maßnahmen und muss für die einen
ausdruck von weitgehend friedlichen und
legitimen protest für andere aber teil
einer aushöhlung strategie von
rechtsextremen und demokratie feinden
mit normalen bürgern als nützlichen
idioten
ok dazu später wir schauen uns das
phänomen spaziergänger genauer an und
die frage wie es um deren unschuld so
steht
[Applaus]
ich selbst und andere zdf kollegen waren
in den letzten wochen auf zahlreichen
demos überall verteilt in deutschland
unterwegs zum beispiel in brandenburg an
münchen in berlin oder im kleinen demo
hotspot ort brackenheim in baden
württemberg die stimmen die man dort
überall hören kann zeigen die ganze
bandbreite des protests und die ist
enorm da ist einmal der völlig legitime
widerspruch und unmut über einzelne
corona maßnahmen oft aus persönlicher
betroffenheit heraus
man sieht auch erstaunlich viele junge
leute die kritisch aber durchaus
differenziert sind geimpfter mit stoffen
umgehen ist mit rohstoffen
das ergibt keinen sinn diese schikanen
bei den älteren verstehe ich ja
zumindest noch etwas aber bei uns
jüngerinnen und dann noch so ein druck
zu machen
nordkorea ist eben auch ein ständiges
abwägen zwischen eigeninteresse und
solidarität freiheit als individuelle
freiheit oder freiheit durch solidarität
mit der gemeinschaft für mich jedenfalls
ist klar widerspruch und infragestellen
der regierungspolitik ist nicht nur
willkommen in ordnung sondern pathetisch
gesagt lebenselexier und dna unserer
freiheitlichen demokratie die ja gerade
davon lebt dass man oder frau anders als
in china oder russland offen anderer
meinung ist und das auch auf der straße
sagen können darf ja soll und dann
sollte quasi als nächster schritt noch
das ventil der wahl da sein also ich bin
zufrieden drücke ich das mit meiner
stimme als wähler aus bin ich nicht
zufrieden weil ich eben eine andere
partei das problem ist dass wenn man
diese leute fragt welche partei sie im
bundestag demokratisch denn eigentlich
vertreten man ganz auf die antwort hört
gar keine mehr
nein überhaupt nicht gar nicht mehr es
gibt bloß noch eine partei aber die kann
man auch nicht wählen und
die kann man auch nicht wählt also ja
weiß er hat recht sind die afg versucht
jedenfalls die proteststimmung
abzuschöpfen und es immer wieder auf
solchen demos präsent mit ihrem neuen
was ihr euch das recht nicht sehen lässt
als wolle man wege und setzt denken
gebirge der mächtige stirn zu bieten
aber so richtig gelingt es ihr nicht
vereinzelt hört man auf den demos im
osten übrigens auch öfter als im westen
klare sympathien für die partei den
meisten aber mit denen wir so auf den
demos sprechen konnten waren
parteipolitisch orientierungslos manche
nannten die protest parteibasis die aber
in den parlamenten überhaupt keine rolle
spielt oder einzelne abgeordnete wie
sahra wagenknecht und den linken oder
wolfgang kubicki von der fdp als ihre
repräsentanten die ihre meinung noch
halbwegs vertreten würden aber die haben
insbesondere wagenknecht ja gar keine
mehrheiten in ihrer partei und die fdp
hat unter den protestierenden massiv an
sympathien verloren
fdp muss ich auch sagen bin ich auch
einfach enttäuscht die hatten ja klare
signale gesandt die bis dato ja alle in
rauchen schall verlaufen sind also alle
die auf die fdp gewartet haben da kann
ich nur lachen wenn man sich im
reichstag umhört bei den demokratischen
parteien in den fluren oder bei den
pressekonferenzen klingt oft
ratlosigkeit und auch übel überforderung
durch im umgang mit dem protest eine
spitzenpolitikerin erzählte mir kürzlich
ganz vertraulich dass sie sich in ihrem
wahlkreis kürzlich mal unter die
demonstrierenden gemischt habe um sich
das mal anzuschauen und selber irgendwie
eine stimmung mitzukriegen und war dann
von der bandbreite völlig überwältigt
also wie unterschiedlich die teilnehmer
gewesen sein die meinte man könne die
gar nicht als gruppe mehr adressieren
design viel zu unterschiedlich und es
sei ein ständiger spagat zwischen
distanz zu den radikalen und dialog zu
den erreichbaren aber man laufe eben
auch immer wieder gegen eine wand gegen
prinzipielle ablehnung der etablierten
politik und des staates insgesamt und
diese enttäuschung von den etablierten
demokratischen parteien das ist das
einfallstor für rechtsextreme und
demokratie feinde erkennbar sind die
aber selten in die ganz klar aber
manchmal kann man es dir dein mikrofon
lügen presse verschwinde anders als die
protestierenden vorne im video lässt
sich die extreme szene für uns
journalisten kaum abbilden da sie uns
selbst als feinde sehen gar nicht mit
uns reden wenn dann irgendwie bepöbeln
jedenfalls nichts offen in ein mikrofon
sagen hey wir sind rechtsextreme und
neonazis und wir wollen die demokratie
abschaffen so läuft es nicht aber es
gibt die so genannten freien sachsen
quasi eine npd truppe mit neuem logo und
ganz erfolgreichen marketing wir haben
im freistaat große teile des protests
unterwandert oder sogar selbst
organisiert und immer wieder kommt es
auch in anderen städten zum
schulterschluss mit ganz rechts zu
gewalt und zu verletzten polizeibeamten
das ist die düstere die schattenseite
der protest medaille der spaziergänger
einen den ich immer wieder treffe auf
den antik ohne massnahmen demos ist levi
salomon vom jüdischen forum für
demokratie und gegen antisemitismus auch
er beobachtet diese szene von anfang an
und erkennt die einschlägigen
rechtsextreme akteure die sich immer
wieder versuchen unter zu mischen von
anfang an weil kann auch nochmals
[Musik]
bundesregierung
rechtsextreme haben sie versucht
309 unternehmen bei dieser demonstration
sie waren für sie überall könnte man
sich hören könnte man sie so
könnte man das ist deren
transparente see liebi salomon
beunruhigt das sehr und was ihm ebenso
beunruhigt und fassungslos macht sind
antisemitismus und holocaust
verharmlosung die auf diesen demos auch
immer wieder auftauchen ich bin mit ihm
auf einer demo in berlin anfang dieses
jahres mal mitgelaufen er hat sie
beobachtet und ich habe ihn beobachtet
und tatsächlich nach wenigen minuten
treffen wir auf eine frau die die
industrielle vernichtung von sechs
millionen juden im dritten reich mit
bestialischen menschen versuchen in eine
reihe stellt mit dem corona impfungen
heute
da wäre ich auch eine ganz starke
parallele für die falls ja was geschah
mit jüdischen ist es ist tief verletzt
wie kann sowas nicht ertragen also neben
dem legitimen protest den wir vorhin am
anfang gehört haben sind auf diesen
demos eben immer wieder auch holocaust
verharmlosung antisemitismus und
rechtsextreme teil des geschehens nicht
immer nicht auf jeder demo aber es
gehört ins gesamtbild des phänomens und
nun kommen wir zur vielleicht
entscheidenden zur spannendsten gruppe
den die zwischen den normalen in
anführungszeichen die berechtigten
widerspruch gegen massnahmen äussern auf
der einen und den verstrahlten
verschwörungs mythen fahrplan holocaust
relativieren und rechtsextrem auf der
anderen seite stehen die spanier gruppe
quasi das sind protestierende die auf
den ersten blick oft harmlos und
irgendwie normal wirken manchmal väter
oder mütter mit kinderwagen die auch mit
dem medien also uns noch sprechen und
teilweise auch berechtigte anliegen
haben man liegt beim zuhören innerlichen
denkt auch wenn das jetzt vielleicht
nicht meine eigene persönliche meinung
trifft ja da hat er oder sie irgendwie
einen punkt bis dann das thema
abgrenzung nach rechtsaußen aufkommen
warum sollte das ein problem sein warum
muss man sich immer dass ganz egal
[Musik]
welche gruppierung diese interessen auf
pappelholz
nicht für nazis und nicht gegen nazis so
lange sie sich irgendwie friedlich geben
das ein oder andere anliegen teilen das
mag auch 1933 mancher gedacht haben die
folgen kennen wir das ist eine fatale
und gefährliche haltung die nur selten
so klar wie in diesem ton unverblümt
geäußert wird klar es gibt auch solche
stimmen zum versuch der unterwanderung
von rechtsextremen und das sind auch
nicht weniger ich würze polizei anzeigen
oder dem versammlungsleiter dass die
person entfernt werden und es gibt auch
zahlreiche
versammlungsleiter und leiterinnen
überall in deutschland die hart
durchgreifen sobald eine
reichskriegsflagge ausgerollt wird die
verzweifelt versuchen ihre demos
extremisten freizuhalten und auch erfolg
mitunter und klar man kann den leuten
auch nicht in den kopf gucken die neben
einem spazieren und das wichtige
grundrecht auf versammlungsfreiheit darf
auch nicht einfach aufgehoben werden
weil jemand extremistisches kommen
könnte damit macht man diese ja
irgendwie auch erst groß und
einflussreich es ist verzwickt
abgrenzung erfordert anstrengung
kontrolle mühe und unangenehme
entscheidungen etwa leute ausschließen
im zweifel mal seine eigene demo selbst
auflösen aber es kann funktionieren und
doch hat man das gefühl viel zu viele
spielen die gefahr in jedoch noch runter
wenn dann von einzelnen rabauken oder
ein paar krawallmachern dir ist nur weil
die wenigen vereinzelten
sonne rabauken sonst was machen wir
warum sollte ich mich dann zurückhaltend
nicht gegen ihn geht mir also irgendwo
muss man dann und marc plagge zeichnet
manager neben mir jemand anfängt den
hitlergruß zu machen dann würde ich mich
davon entfernen die sicherheitsbehörden
aber finden den versuch der
rechtsextreme unterwanderung gar nicht
lustig sondern sehen eben eine massive
gefahr auch wenn sie betonen dass
natürlich der großteil der
demonstrierenden selbst weder
gewalttätig noch rechtsextreme seien wir
haben explizit wortführerin und
wortführer die mindestens ganz nahe dran
sind am rechten rechtsextremistischen
spektrum dabei wird ganz offen über den
umsturz über den widerstand der ja
salonfähig gemacht werden soll das volk
wird quasi zum angeblich legitimen
widerstand gegen die korona diktatur
aufgerufen widerstand gegen die
angebliche corona diktatur als
gemeinsame klammer mit bürgerlichen
protest genau das ist der traum von
rechtsextremen in deutschland dafür soll
die straße und die herzen und die hirne
der in anführungszeichen normalen
protestierenden gewonnen werden aber das
zu verhindern ist die aufgabe der
demokratischen parteien so sehe ich das
jedenfalls differenzieren angebote
machen gespräche suchen zumindest bis zu
einem gewissen punkt um das fällt eben
nicht den zu überlassen die legitimen
widerspruch instrumentalisieren um dann
ein land nach ihren gefährlichen
vorstellungen zu schaffen in dem
widerspruch eben nicht mehr vorgesehen
ist der spaziergang hat seine unschuld
verloren hat er recht der
bundespräsident was meint ihr und wenn
ja wie lässt sich die unschuld des
spaziergangs zurückgewinnen schreibt es
in die kommentare und wenn ihr noch mehr
interessante videos sehen wollt
abonniert und seinen kanal denn unsere
videos sind sicherlich kein spaziergang